we're talking with Jason Riley author of
let them in the case for open borders
six common arguments against immigration
and why they are wrong let's start right
away doom and demography why are fears
about a demographic disaster wrong well
because there's no correlation between
population growth and economic
prosperity sub-saharan Africa is one of
the most sparsely populated regions of
the earth it's also one of the poorest
Hong Kong is one of the most densely
populated regions of the earth it's also
one of the richest there's just simply
no correlation there it's not something
we need to concern ourselves with
economics fears about an economic
disaster there aren't a fixed number of
jobs in the u.s. our labor markets are
very flexible and we're going to help
keep them that way and it's just untrue
that an immigrant coming here to take a
job means one fewer job for the people
already here welfare the measure of a
man well most low-skilled immigrants are
poor but among poor residents of the
u.s. immigrants are not heavy welfare
users illegal immigrants don't even
qualify for federal welfare programs and
among the immigrants who do qualify for
public benefits they use welfare at
lower rates than natives I should also
add that if your concern is is that some
immigrants are receiving more on public
benefits and they pay in taxes you
should keep in mind that so does 67
percent of Americans
assimilation the nativist are restless
our immigrants assimilating yes they are
assimilating and it's sometimes it's
hard to detect that because we're still
in the middle of the latest wave of
Mexicans but when you do longitudinal
studies that measure the same folks over
time you see not only assimilation
taking place but also upward social
mobility you have one of the arguments
is called pup tent republicanism what
what do you mean there I mean that the
the the Latino vote is not lost to the
Republican Party I think George Bush
proved this in 2004 they should go out
and work for this vote not conceded to
Democrats how do they get the Latino
vote well one way you get it is not
being anti Latino just showing these
people that you care about their
situation and that your party has
something to offer them other than then
then a sort of demagoguery I I think you
make them feel welcome that's what
Reagan did
that's what Bush tried to do and I think
that's who the Republican Party should
be looking for for leadership on this
issue not lou dobbs homeland security
are are immigrants are Mexican
immigrants a threat to security no
they're not a threat to security only in
the sense that they run interference for
the bad guys who want to sneak in
amongst them and which is why I think we
should give economic migrants from Latin
America more legal ways to come reduce
that interference shrink the haystack
and let our Border Patrol focus on the
real threats what is the best case
against immigration or current levels or
increased levels of immigration
I can't think of a case against
immigration I can't our whole history of
this country argues against it I mean I
I can't think of a good reason to seal
the border I can only think of bad
reasons to seal the border and I'm not
arguing that the u.s. can't survive
without access to foreign labor I mean
I'm not saying this country will go to
hell in a handbasket but economics is
about trade-offs it's about weighing the
cost and the benefits of alternative
courses of action I just think we're
better off with immigrants than we are
without them also not arguing that there
are no cost associated with immigrants
particularly low-skilled immigrants
I'm just arguing that the benefits far
outweigh this cost in the long run can
you give a quick shorthand what what are
those costs and what are those benefits
have who what's the best calculation
well border border states face cost in
terms of education in terms of health
care I think those costs are overstated
often but they're real and I think that
the best way to deal with them is not
more walls and fences but probably some
sort of revenue sharing with the federal
government who comes out ahead on these
issues because most illegal immigrants
here work on the books they're paying
payroll taxes and other federal taxes
into systems where they'll never receive
the benefits from so Uncle Sam is coming
out way ahead
but states and localities could use some
of that booty shared with them back at
the state level and I would argue for
some some revenue sharing to go on there
now rather than building walls and
fences
I want to thank Jason Riley of the Wall
Street Journal editorial board for
coming to discuss his new book let them
in the case for open borders with Reason
TV for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie